هذه امراه امريكيه اعلنت عن زواجها من رجل
حلو حلو هذا الرجل افتراضي يعمل بواسطه
الذكاء الاصطناعي معتبره انه شريك المثالي
حره روزانا راموس مشاهدينا هي ام لطفلين
يعني جربت الزواج قبل ذلك تزوجت من الرجل
الافتراضي الان اسمه ايرين بعد ان التقت
به العام الماضي عبر خدمه مواعده عبر
الانترنت وفقا طبعا لتقرير نشرته صحيفه
روزانا قالت ان علاقتها بحبيبها الجديد
افضل من علاقاتها السابقه ووصفته بانه يحب
الموسيقى
والكتابه كهوايه
احنا طبعا نرى الصور بعض الصور بالفعل
والله يعني رجل افتراضي جميل جدا اجمل
منها الحقيقه على كل حال من المثير
مشاهدينا للاهتمام ان الرجل كان مستوحى من
شخصيه معروفه من مجموعه اليابانيه هجوم
العمالقه
انا خايف انا خايف على احد ببالي كل هم
يحب المانجا بس كل اشي صار هلا بالذكاء
هذا مش مستغرب يا عادل والله
البرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات